let's talk about the benefits of
nutritional yeast i primarily recommend
nutritional yeast mainly for a natural
source of vitamin b1 now i realize that
if you're going to buy nutritional yeast
a lot of times they fortify it and they
fortify it with synthetic b vitamins
which are sourced from things like coal
tar
acetate ammonia hydrochloric acid
well i just want to let you know a
synthetic b1 is not the same as a
natural b1 synthetics are a lot cheaper
natural b1 is a lot more expensive
because you have to use a lot more raw
material from some natural source to get
a very tiny amount of the vitamin but
what you're going to find out
it's totally worth it the effects that
the b vitamins specifically b1 has on
the body are pretty dramatic especially
nowadays as it relates to this thing
called stress but there's a couple
confusions that people have when you're
talking about
nutritional yeast first of all they
think if you're going to consume
nutritional yeast they're going to get a
yeast infection that's absolutely not
true you're consuming deactivated yeast
but mainly the byproducts of what yeast
create they are b vitamin
machines they make b vitamins they make
amino acids
in fact nutritional yeast is a complete
protein it has all of the essential
amino acids
it has quite a few trace minerals too
like selenium for the conversion from t4
to t3 it also has zinc and copper which
is very important in your immune system
in building testosterone it has chromium
which is really good for blood sugars it
is loaded with phosphorus which makes up
something called atp adenosine
triphosphate which is the energy
currency of your body it'll give you
more energy and nutritional yeast has
something else called beta glucan you
may have heard of that when people are
talking about oatmeal or consuming
cheerios because these grains are so
called
heart healthy because beta glucan is a
type of fiber that can help lower your
cholesterol but what about all the
carbohydrates and cereals that's going
to raise insulin and create
other issues but beta-glucan can also
help with the immune system but out of
the b vitamins the trace minerals the
protein amino acids and the beta glucan
i usually take nutritional yeast for
vitamin b1 everything else is kind of
like a side note all right let's just
talk about b1 for a minute b1
is the most important
water soluble vitamin vitamin d is the
most important
fat soluble vitamin and this is just
because
how intimately b1 is needed
in all of your cells in the energy
factory of your cells called the
mitochondria when you take oxygen and
you have fuel
and you add a spark plug
you get energy right so that spark plug
is thymine b1 without the spark plug
without b1
you cannot generate energy if you give
the mitochondria too much fuel as in a
high carb diet you're going to flood the
engine much like i did with my atv
last week in fact it just wouldn't start
and so eventually took out the spark
plug and there was just way too much gas
that was flooding the engine and i had
to completely clean all that out before
i can get the spark plug to fire
correctly so in our bodies if we have
too much glucose too many carbohydrates
the requirement for b1 goes dramatically
higher and if you're not consuming the
b1
you're going to be completely tired all
the time
that's called chronic fatigue syndrome
so one of the big benefits of
nutritional yeast
is it gives you energy it's great for
athletes to maintain endurance but
there's some other really cool benefits
that i want to i want to mention but
first i need to explain
part of the brain called the limbic
system
has different structures in it that do
different things related to
homeostasis which is the
body's ability to adapt to the
environment to maintain a constant state
of function internally and also you have
the autonomic nervous system that's
working with this system so we have both
the flight or fight mechanism and we
have the rest and digest
parasympathetic nervous system so
sympathetic and parasympathetic one
system is trying to speed everything up
and adapt to stress the other system is
trying to calm things down
help you digest and help you sleep at
night and so out of all the structures
in the brain the limbic system
is the part that needs a tremendous
amount of oxygen there's a lot of
oxidation going on in the limbic system
and so the need for b1
is really really high and so that part
of the brain is very susceptible
to a vitamin b1 deficiency and one part
of that system
called the amygdala
gives you the emotion of fear it's a
survival mechanism and so
if you are deficient in b1
you're going to find that you have
different
states of fear like anxiety
you feel nervous you feel a panicky
if you're sleeping at night and you have
nightmares that means you're deficient
in b1 what is a nightmare well those are
different pictures that give you fear in
fact they did experiments in animals
where they took the amygdala out of
these animals and they had no fear now
that's very dangerous from a survival
mechanism because if you see
a poisonous snake and you're not afraid
of it and it bites you you die
so we need fear to help us survive now
what about panic attacks
that is a severe b1 deficiency so taking
nutritional yeast can greatly help
anxiety and stress and make you feel
very very calm and it usually takes
within probably a few minutes after
consuming it and by the way you can get
nutritional yeast as a powder which is a
little difficult to take because you
have to kind of mix with something or
you can get it in a tablet i put some
information down below but if you get in
a tablet i highly recommend that you
chew it you don't swallow it because a
lot of times the tablets are a little
bit big now what does it taste like well
some people like to taste some people
don't like the taste so i would just
look at it like this even though the
taste might not be that great it's going
to make you feel really good so the
feeling that you get from it is going to
be a huge benefit so nutritional yeast
lowers anxiety stress
panic attacks helps get rid of
nightmares and it really helps to
decrease
irritability and definitely the
sensation of feeling aggravated
if you have a low tolerance to stress so
let's say for example you can't tolerate
i don't know babysitting 18 small
children
in a room for over eight hours or
you just for some reason don't like
someone that's driving very very slow in
front of you then you may benefit from
nutritional yeast now let's say for
example you make a lot of coffee and you
feel this nervous jittery
kind of feeling
nutritional yeast boom it just will
handle that very quickly or let's say
for example you go to bed at night and
you start thinking and thinking and
excessively the thoughts just keep going
and you can't turn them off
nutritional yeast so a really good time
to take nutritional yeast is actually
right before you go to bed even though
it increases energy it won't keep you up
at night
in fact it kind of will calm down things
so you can drift off into a night's
sleep it definitely enhances your sleep
more than anything else also because
nutritional yeast is loaded with the
trace minerals and amino acids
it's really good for your hair so if
you're losing hair nutritional yeast
could help you nutritional yeast also
can help a condition called pots this is
the condition where you stand up and you
feel dizzy and you might feel like you
want to faint or pass out
that is
part of the autonomic nervous system's
inability to adapt to
stress the stress of standing up where
all the blood flow has to go to your
brain so if you don't have enough b1
you will develop pots
also nutritional yeast can actually give
you the b1 necessary to
overcome
climbing up a hill
without getting winded so if you're
climbing upstairs and your legs are
heavier that would be a perfect
indication for nutritional yeast because
it's going to support the autonomic
nervous system's ability to cope with
physical stress all right another uh
really positive benefit is your pulse
rate your autonomic nervous system
controls a lot of things but it
definitely controls the pacemaker and
your pulse rate so if you're deficient
in b1
you might find that your pulse rate goes
higher and higher and higher
you might find that you get palpitations
nutritional yeast can help you with that
another thing that is connected with the
b1 deficiency is your breathing let's
say your breathing is off which it
usually is during a stress event well
nutritional yeast can help you with that
because anything that is connected to
the autonomic nervous system can be
improved with vitamin b1 now the other
interesting thing that a b1 deficiency
will manifest as is either
excessive hunger or no appetite a mild
b1 deficiency
will cause you not to be satisfied after
you eat something so you're going to
want to keep eating something and you're
just not going to be satisfied but a
very severe b1 deficiency can cause you
to lose your appetite so apparently the
centers in the brain
that are the sayety centers that help
satisfy you are very vulnerable to a b1
deficiency and the last symptom that
could happen with a b1 deficiency that
can be improved with nutritional yeast
is just general confusion
lack of clarity lack of
focus and that has to do with another
part of the brain which i'm not going to
get into but a b1 deficiency can keep
you in a state of confusion which things
are just not clear for you so anyway i
wanted to talk about the benefits of
nutritional yeast
now if you haven't seen my comprehensive
video
on vitamin b1 that i did at one of the
keto summits
it's quite interesting check it out i
put it right here
you